the hype house is getting a reality show
which i
cannot wait to watch how involved will
you be in that
i am not a hundred percent sure how
involved i'm gonna be with it i'm sure
it's really here and there but i don't
have like a lead role or anything
have they started filming it do you know
no
not yet okay will everyone who's part of
the hype
brand whether or not they are like a
lead role
or not be a part of it or like do you
know
i'm actually not 100 sure we haven't
talked about it that much
um i assume there's like different
pieces and bits that we're all gonna
like take play in
but i'm not sure it's not gonna be like
a big thing if we do
what i know you don't know that much but
what do you think as viewers
yeah we would learn about the hype house
i think
we would learn a lot about our sense of
humor
on social media everything is taken
super seriously
and i always tell people i'm like you
literally can't hurt my feelings i live
with all boys like i
literally get made fun of for everything
that i do
so it's just kind of like i've gotten
used to like the concept
just like little like bickering and like
arguing i've never had a brother before
so it was
very different to like moving to a
ginormous house full of
like 15 guys so it was definitely
interesting yeah yeah i think just
everyone will figure out like everyone's
personalities are very different
i feel like every reality show there's
always some element of drama
what drama like could we potentially
i have no idea honestly like everyone
gets along
perfectly no it's definitely not that we
all
i mean for the most part we do get along
and there's never like really like
arguments in the house unless it's like
we're arguing about like what time
people stay up until um that's like
probably the worst arguing we get into
is like people being loud at like 3 a.m
everyone's like shut up
for the most part i know i think they're
gonna um
like have a few new people be on set so
i honestly
i myself don't know like a ton about it
well tell me about this
move because you moved into a new house
with
i think nate with taylor is it still
considered a hype house or is it
so we're not calling ourselves anything
we don't have a name um
we are still under like the high house
umbrella um
like we're still associated with them
like if they have any like events or
whatever we'll probably
be there what prompted the move like was
it
your guys's decision were you like the
hype house has too many freaking people
in it i want my own bedroom like that
yeah we were just very crammed in this
tiny little
i mean the house itself is not small at
all but it was
17 people living in i think like a
13 14 bedroom house and
it just after a while you kind of are
like i want some more space
so yeah who all lives in the the new
house with you
oh it's markelle washington
nate shawn which is
taylor's like at-home friend cody which
i mean sean is the videographer
photographer cody is taylor's at-home
friend
um and then taylor and then kelly do you
think that you guys will name your house
um not
really i think we'll just we're like
sponsored by trailer we love trailers so
i think we're just kind of like going
under like that section of the well
like trailer um sponsoring us so and
we're just gonna make this house super
like activity friendly um just because
we do have a
lot of land in the backyard that's like
the whole reason why we moved out here
um we're all the way in calabasas so
we're very far
um but yeah we're gonna get like pit
bike tracks and like a pool and like a
bunch of like
skating stuff so we kind of just have
like a bunch of fun and we don't have
like that many neighbors i mean
jake paul is literally my next-door
neighbor so
we're gonna have like people getting mad
at us so yeah hey
how is it to have jake paul as your
neighbor i've interviewed jake
multiple times he is a character
yes he's definitely they're not there
right now because they're in vegas
have you guys been filming content with
jake
um not right now but i'm sure in the
future we will
obviously with the houses there is sway
house and bryce who i've
interviewed multiple times has made some
comments about the hype house i'm sure
you've have you seen those
um i'd probably recognize them if i saw
them
he just i mean he sort of poked fun at
the way that the hype house spends money
oh yeah what did you
make of his comments are you guys
friendly is there i think i'm personally
new with of sway i'm
friends with all of them um i literally
have nothing against any of them
um they're boys they're normal teenage
boys
exactly you're gonna act like every
teenage boy
bryce is a character bryce is a very
funny person
you did say that you guys are sponsored
by triller so what does that mean
for tick-tock and like your content
moving forward like will you put more of
an emphasis
on sharing things to triller like do you
definitely yeah i'll be posting a lot on
trailer just because i
like posting on all my social medias
people are always like olivia you post
so much and i was like
i enjoy posting that's probably if i
didn't like posting i probably wouldn't
be doing social media yeah yeah
but yeah i'll definitely be posting a
lot on trailers i'll be posting a lot
with like
my friends we're posting a lot of like
the house everywhere
um like house tours on like little house
tours all of our beds
um just different like funny content
like crazy stuff that
we're doing in the house because i
literally live with some of the craziest
people and
jake's yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be
fun so just make sure
that i feel like you are 18 but like
yet you understand these men that you're
living with so well already you're like
you just take everything with a grain of
salt like you put up with a lot of stuff
i think that would be hard for a lot of
girls to do but you do it with such
ease how like it was hard for a little
bit
just kind of getting used to like
certain like little like side notes like
you know like girls would go through
emotions you know
yeah because i've had to just be like
they're boys olivia it doesn't matter
i'm definitely like way more stronger in
that sense um
just having to go through everything at
once like while moving like
the relationships the whole like
friendships all everything was just
being thrown at me no matter like two
months i just had to learn an insane
amount in
such a little time so i am personally
very blessed that i had to do all that
because i know so much more now
kudos to you for
um becoming part of the hype house and
having
so many followers obviously that comes
with a lot of speculation
a lot of scrutiny how have you
handled that aspect of it i like almost
see it as kind of a motivation to the
point where people are like coming and
looking at what i'm doing
and if they have something mean to say
i'm gonna be like okay well if you have
something mean to say i'm gonna go
and do it better so next time you don't
have anything for me today
but then on the other hand like i really
kind of have stopped
looking at like my comment section and
like seeing what people do actually say
about me
i've kind of like just been trying to
get at peace with myself
because i think if you're at peace with
yourself then what other people say
about you shouldn't affect
the way you feel about yourself what
have you learned about
yourself as you've sort of seen your
career kind of skyrocket
learned about myself that's like
i would say that
i can do a lot on my own which i did not
know i could do all this
i think it's an honest blessing in my
point of view
that this did all the happen i've
learned a lot with
almost that i'm a very introverted
person
but i probably have like a few nights a
week where i'm like oh that like i want
to go out to dinner with like someone so
and so and so
and i've really learned like my solid
group of people and i
i do actually really love making friends
which is
kind of something new that i've learned
because i am very introverted
i love going out to dinner and just like
meeting new people and whether it's like
the waitress or like the security guard
like i really don't care
but that would probably be like a few
things i've learned